today it's alec bettinger day he makes
his major league debut he was drafted by
the brewers in the 10th round back in
2017 out of the university of virginia
and no season last year but 2019 double
a biloxi 26 starts good numbers for him
to first pitch swing from mookie betts
as sky high pop up colt wong sunglasses
on a little different result than the
first pitch of the game yesterday that
mookie bets it out of the ballpark
bettinger officially hasn't earned run
average and there are two on for the
dodgers with only one man out
to right
peeling towards the line long run garcia
foul ground makes the catch
two away now
for alec bettinger
hits him slipped out of his hand bases
loaded for baity and the pitch
swung on little roller past the mound
right side it's gonna be a tough play
and safe at first as baity
the throw by the first baseman huro came
way off the bag and fielded he had to
throw it to bettinger seeger comes in to
score and the dodgers lead at one
nothing bettinger just could not find
the bag with his foot so the base is
still loaded and now aj pollock and the
pitch
swung on hit deep to center field back
goes bradley looks up it is gone a grand
slam
aj pollock with a grand slam a second of
his career
and the dodgers
strike big time in the first inning one
big collective sigh of relief from the
dodgers a five spot in the first inning
it's also nice that you have a five run
cushion so you don't have to be too fine
to make sure you go out there trust your
stuff and pound that strike zone and so
aureus trying to put the team on his
shoulders today and go deep into this
game maria stewano two and the first
breaking ball he throws gets a swing and
a miss for strike three this is a great
pitch by william julius with that
breaking ball to get the swing in the
miss
one on one out for a viseo garcia
that's it short seeger on a short hop
will turn a 6-4-3
double play
mookie bats will lead things off again
for the dodgers bouncer hit to a diving
backhanded stab and a long throw by
pablo reyes what a play
wow
diving backhanded stabbed to take an
extra base hit away from mookie betts
and then a cannon-like throw to first
to retire the speedster the base is
loaded and matt beatty at the plate he
golfs the first pitch to deep right
garcia's back at the wall
it's gone
the second grand slam of the day
baby's first of the season
it's 9-0
good to see you offense
and making that one a huge
swing by matt beatty pablo reyes
julio straightens up the left-hander
kicks fires and the breaking ball check
swing did he go julio's already walking
off the mound yep that's strike three
so that'll be the second strikeout for
julio and julius as he gets pablo reyes
ground ball to third diving stop again
by reyes and he robs another hit for
mookie betts oh boy what kind of glove
does he have we saw him in spring
training we saw some pretty good defense
but
he is putting on a show out there at
third base good for him the brewers were
able to reacquire nottingham from the
seattle mariners he was designated for
assignment by the brewers on april 22nd
right on cue he drives onto deep right
center field the sheriff is back in town
first at bat back with the crew and he
goes deep that's strong i'm telling you
that was a breaking pitch from aureus
and waded back and just hammered it out
there towards the toyota territory wow
strong
good for jacob nottingham he's worked
hard
82 for two with the grand slam and an
rbi single
beatty again
into center field and in three at bats
he's driven in seven dodgers 11 brewers
one with seven rbis from matt beatty
square this one up as well
get the barrel to this ball and knock
into right center
two gone for bradley
reaches out and drags that tapper to
second for noisy to finish off the
fourth
11-1 dodgers as we play in the top of
the fifth and a big welcome home jordan
zimmerman pitching for his hometown club
and making his first appearance with the
brewers that one is whacked to second
and
the play made by kesten hura 4-3 if you
go along with us two in the inning two
on and no bonnie out and the batter is
matt beatty who has had a nice afternoon
baby to center field jackie bradley jr
makes the catch maybe the hardest hit
ball of the day for beatty and it's the
first time he's been retired pollock hit
the first of the two grand slams today
he hits one in the air left center field
back there
gone
a two home run game for aj pollock
he's driven in seven
pollick and beatty tied at seven apiece
the game is 14-1
people be going to the record books this
is the seventh time a team has had two
players yeah seven or more rbis in the
same game
was in a pretty comfortable spot even on
his first pitch of the day he was
beneficial he's out there for the bottom
of the six volkl back down swinging one
away here in the sixth henries his
seventh strikeout
tyrone taylor one for two breaking ball
popped up
center field calling for it is
chris taylor he's got the glasses on he
looks up into the sunny sky makes the
catch for the up two out here's garcia
got him swinging
ten pitch inning for julio rios who's
got eight strikeouts today
facing casting hero out of eight k's no
walks today a swing and a miss and a
center-cut fast ball here continues to
search for it as urias racks up his
ninth luis urias
grounded a third knocked down by noisy
recovers
throws one of the dirt over there the
rios picks out how is it out to gone
there's the one two on the way and a
swing and a miss and jackie bradley jr
strikes out that's ten punk shots for
julio aureus that's 12 in a row set down
also by the dodger left-hander pollock
has hit a grand slam in the first and a
three-run homer in the six
he yanks one down the line deep towards
the corner off the wall
into scores taylor
eight rbis for aj [ __ ] just barely
missing a third home run and a franchise
record 10 rbis
that first vogel back
oh
i've just barely got there
brady in the score 16-1
it's not over yet 15 to tie why not get
16.
nottingham to right is he going to be
able to keep it fair it's headed towards
the corner it is fair
another home run for jacob nottingham
his second of the game hey go give him
something to think about a couple of
opposite field home runs for jacob
nottingham
that'll be a base hit for robbie garcia
driving in another run making it 16-4
the mistakes that kick him has made have
been with the slider
two gone in the ninth inning billy
mckinney the last hope for the brewers
keep things moving he gets back-to-back
case to finish things off dodgers with
an angry win today 16 runs a season high